placements welcome to the forge all
right ben you have the choice of the
weapon or the forge welding technique
the weapon
all right we've got quite the assortment
here all of which look pretty daunting
what are you thinking let's go with the
zephos
the zephos all right
the xefos is a leaf blade double-edged
sword and just super cool and very
iconic for the gladiators
the zephos first saw battle back in 7th
century bc greece but was so effective
it also saw action in the hands of
gladiators in the coliseum featuring a
short double-edged leaf-shaped blade
with a sharp tip
this weapon was designed to inflict
brutal thrust and slashes against an
enemy in close quarter combat
the zephos was previously featured in
season three of forged and fire where a
loose pummel ultimately cost one smith
the competition we have eight hours of
the clock for this battle
so good luck stay sharp your time starts
now
i'm choosing to do two separate stacks
of ten layers because i need two
outside billets that i can then put onto
my adcrv2
i'm feeling pretty good about this forge
weld and now it's just drawing it out to
that 19 inches ben's at the point with
that ability his that he needs to pull
or that thing with the power hammer die
i'm able to stretch that steel out
pretty nice getting it closer to that
final shape that i want so once i get my
billet drawn out and to shape i'd start
cleaning it and all of a sudden
[Music]
oh
it smacked me right in my face
everything looks pretty symmetrical so
now i'm ready to start getting this
thing prepped for quench
uh ben's in the oil
looks straight i feel good so now it's
just letting it cool down and ultimately
starting to put my bevels in once it
cools
now i'm ready to get my bevels ground in
leaf blades are double-edged and so it's
not only two bevels but four bevels so
it's just time-consuming making sure
that everything's nice and symmetrical
looking at my handle i realize it's a
little too long so i gotta shorten up
the handle so that
the whole piece is the right size for a
handle my handle is feeling good now i'm
ready to go put an edge on this thing
for my damascus i'm using 10 layers of
1095 and 10 layers of 5920. jessie's
setting his wells by hand again again
what you're comfortable with
[Music]
the billet is really solid
so i go over to the press and start
drawing the billet out
my damascus pieces are a lot wider than
my adc or v2 pieces
so it's crucial that i get these
centered correctly as i'm drawing the
billet out on the forging press i think
the welds have set really well but i
can't tell because of the overhanging
layers
there's a cold shut around my entire
billet
but i don't know how far this cold shot
goes until i go to the grinder and start
peeling it open i'm beyond relieved the
culture only goes along the edge it does
not go through and i am still in this
it's time to start forging this blade to
shape
maniac
oh we're looking at a quench here pretty
soon
i'm more than halfway through the eight
hours if this quench fails i'm screwed
here we go
i heard no pings or pops during the
quench i take it out
file test it and it skates like ice
perfect now that i'm quenched i take the
blade over to the grinder and begin
hogging off material
as i'm grinding off the welds i see that
i do not have clean material
if this weld is weak my pommel is gonna
fly off when they test it and i cannot
have that i grind off the welds and it
is perfect it looks like one homogenous
piece of steel
thank god that worked and now it's time
to start finally grinding my handle to
shape
this is the least time i've ever had to
shape a handle i have to make sure that
there's no sharp edges on my pommel or
guard that could cut a judge's hand with
just seconds left on the clock i sharpen
the blade as best i can
five
four
three
two
one fight spins turn off the machines
put down your tools this battle is
officially over
heck of a matchup
all right gentlemen it's time for our
strength test the roman pot shop
and jesse you are up first you ready
yes yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay jesse right off uh when i grab this
that handles a good good size for me as
far as your edge holding up i mean i can
feel
some loss of sharpness but man where i
didn't hit a pot
it's definitely a sharp blade
but i think he did a great job on the
balance the look of this is sweet the
scale is right on nicely done
thank you
ben
you ready yes sir okay cool
[Music]
[Applause]
all right ben right off
could use a little bit more handle but i
like the transitions you've got from
handle to pummel and from handle to
guard as far as the edge of your blade
goes you've got a lot of rolling uh
there's a couple of spots that there are
actually little sharp burrs but
everything's right and tight felt good
held up well nicely done thank you
gladiators of the forge looks like it's
coming down to this
this is the sharpness test
the flying sandbag slice
jesse up first you ready for this yep
let's do this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right jesse let's talk about your
sifus sword right here it's got a great
nice feel to it the balance of this is
really good and talking about your edge
it slices and i can move around with
your weapon overall sir you're sifus
you look up
thank you
all right ben your turns are you ready
let's do it let's have some fun
[Applause]
[Music]
all right ben let's talk about your cfo
sword here your handle it's smooth
it's just a little bit small for my
hands i'd rather have something girthier
in there so that when i'm wheeling this
i really have good control of it but the
areas where you suffered a little bit of
rolling were not an issue it cut nicely
on these bags
overall sir
you're cephos
thank you
well gentlemen from the moment you
stepped into this coliseum it was clear
that you came here ready to fight but in
this competition only one of you can
come out of this battle as a gladiator
to the forge and receive a check for
five thousand dollars the winner
of this gladiator forge battle is
jesse you did it again congratulations
now ben you are clearly a force to be
reckoned with but unfortunately your
blade did not make the cut all of us
want to say thank you so much for coming
to this battle and fighting so hard but
unfortunately at this time i'm gonna
have to ask you to please step off the
fourth floor thank you gentlemen for the
opportunity check you congratulations
great job man jesse you're an incredible
smith a great guy go on and win the
entire thing brother
jesse that makes you a two-time
gladiator forge you are now at a total
of ten thousand dollars congratulations
thank you
i just won two battles in a row i i'm so
happy i have ten thousand dollars in my
wallet now and i still have the
opportunity to win more
i'm gonna have to email my professors
and tell them i can't come to class
because who knew i would be here i'm
here to win my plan is to go as far as i
can hopefully to the end of all of the
gladiator battles
you